[Musique]
TF1 20h avec Roger Giquel DC10 malgré
les vérifications Washington maintient
l'interdiction de tout décollage pour
les appareils des compagnies nationales
et à l'instant l'administration
américaine vient de prendre la même
décision pour les
Airbus limitation de vitesse renforcée
fauses rumeurs mais contrôle plus sévère
sur les
routes le pacte national pour l'emploi
des jeunes devient officiel demain sur S
chôur 39 on moins de 25
ans bonne surprise à Roland Garros Noah
passe avec panache le premier
tour bonsoir oui il faut revenir
longuement sur le premier titre de ce
journal quelque part l'information a mal
circulé et c'est grave sur
l'interdiction de vol des DCDi aux
États-Unis hier on avait cru comprendre
que cette interdiction était toute
provisoire qu'il s'agissait seulement
d'immobiliser les DC1 pour vérifier leur
système d'attache des réacteurs et
d'ailleurs c'est comme cela qu'en France
pour l'UTA par exemple et dans tous les
autres pays du monde pour les compagnies
qui ont des DC10 on avait interprété les
choses toutes les compagnies dont l'UTA
ont annoncé qu'elles vérifiaent leurs
avions ces vérifications ont été dans le
monde dans le monde entier relativement
rapide quelques heures et puis
l'exploitation ne s'est pas arrêté les
vols ont continué or nouveau coup de
théâtre ce soir aux États-Unis
l'administration fédérale a confirmé il
y a un instant seulement que tous les
décèd Américains étaient vraiment
interdits de vol je dis bien interdit de
vol parce qu'on a découvert des défauts
graves et et potentiellement dangereux
dans l'assemblage des pilons d'attache
des pilones d'attache des réacteurs il
ne s'agit donc plus de la défaillance
d'un simple boulon et il ne s'agit plus
seulement des des DC10 puisque
Washington on vous l'a dit tout à
l'heure a annoncé il y a seulement
quelques minutes que les Airbus A300
sont interdits de vol aux États-Unis
parce que le montage des moteurs d'il de
ce type d'avion est similaire à celui du
DC10 alors pour l'instant restons au
DC10 de Washington Dominique
Bromberger il n'y avait eu que quelques
vols annulés au milieu de l'un des
weekends de plus intense trafic aérien
de toute l'année simplement dans les
hangars une activités constante sur les
DC10 des diverses compagnies aériennes
l'administration de l'aviation civile
dans un premier temps n'avait demandé
une chose vérifier le boulon qui attache
le réacteur à l'elle et la cloison du
support du réacteur à partir du moment
où le responsable de tout le mal était
ce boulon le diagnostic et la réparation
était simple et pouvait être mené
relativement rapidement vous n'avez qu'à
enlever la cloison enlever le boulon en
question et remplacer un autre suivant
les indications du
constructeur maises American Airlines la
compagnie qui avait subi le désastre ne
s'en était pas tenu à cette explication
toutes les pièces critiques de
l'appareil avaient ét enlevés des lieux
pour être
examiné et en Californie chez McDonald
Douglas le constructeur la prudence
était de rigueur avec en tout et pour
tout ces jours derniers une seule
déclaration nous nous refusons à établir
un lien unique et direct entre ce boulon
et
l'accident si la presse américaine avait
handemain de Chicago rappeler que le
DC10 avait déjà subi plusieurs accidents
une espèce d'unanimité s'était établie
de la part des porte-paroles des
compagnies aériennes ou des dirigeants
de l'aviation civile pour dire le DC10
est un bon avion à l'exception de ce
boulon hier pourtant un représentant du
conseil pour la sécurité des transports
avait déclaré si un desc10 est conçu
pour voler sur deux réacteurs il aurait
dû pouvoir prendre de l'altitude puis se
poser même en ayant perdu un réacteur il
semble bien que ce soit le diagnosticque
de cet observateur unique qui en fin de
compte est été juste l'administration de
l'aviation civile vient en effet
d'annoncer à l'instant même que tous les
DC10 américains étaient désormais
interdit de vol jusqu'à nouvel ordre à
cause cela à cause de graves défauts
dans l'assemblage des réacteurs avec les
ailes on a en effet découvert la trace
d'usure de métal sur d'autres DCDi en
service à travers le monde ce sont 274
DC10 qui sont en fonctionnement
transportant 135000 passagers par jour
un chiffre à vous donner le frisson
Dominique Bromberger TF1 Washington
alors maintenant il faut bien sûr
s'attendre certainement à un changement
de position des différents pays et des
différentes compagnies qui exploitent
ces desc10 et aussi il faut s'attendre à
des réactions concernant l'erbus A300
dont je vous rappelle que les Américains
l'ont interdit de vol aujourd'hui sur
leur territoire parce que disent-il les
réacteurs sont fixés avec le même
assemblage que sur ce sur les ailes du
DC10 et il faut donc attendre les
réactions des constructeurs de l' a bus
que nous n'avons pas encore puisque la
nouvelle de cette interdiction de la 300
Airbus n'est tombé qu'il y a quelques
minutes la vie de l'automobiliste est
pleine d'angoisse il y a les traites de
la voiture la vignette l'essence et
toutes les taxes qui vont avec ça fait
déjà beaucoup de soucis surtout quand le
carburant augmente régulièrement ensuite
il y a la route qui n'est pas sûre d'où
les contraintes de sécurité auxquelles
il faut se plier et on s'y plie exemple
la limitation de vitesse on finit par
accepter tout ça y compris la peur du
gendarme et l'accident toujours possible
malgré tout même quand il quand on y est
pour rien or voilà que ce matin
l'automobiliste s'est réveillé avec une
une mauvaise nouvelle supplémenta les
radios reprenaient une information
lancée au conditionnel bien sûr par
notre confrère Maurice Cazo du journal
de Figaro et selon laquelle la vitesse
sur les autoroutes serait bientôt
limitée à 110 km à l'heure au lieu de
130 les 130 à l'heure c'est déjà
difficile à tenir avec une grande partie
des voitures actuellement sur le marché
alors comment se contenter de rouler à
110 sur l'autoroute avec tout t les
chevaux dont on dispose les
constructeurs automobiles commençaient à
lever les bras au ciel et bien ce soir
on peut dire non la limitation à 110 à
l'heure sur autoroute n'est pas envisagé
pas plus que les 80 km sur route
ordinaire au lieu de 90 ou les 50 à
l'heure en ville au lieu de 60 nous
avons consulté tous les ministères
concernés il n'en est pas question
cependant ces limitations ont bien
figuré parmi toutes les hypothèses du
gouvernement pour économiser l'énergies
le ministère de l'Industrie a même fait
référence dans ses projets à ce qui se
passe au États-Unis là-bas on a on a dit
Ben et bien on a fait remarqué que la
vitesse sur autoroute sur autoroute est
limitée à 80 km à l'heure ça fait 55
miles quelqu'un au ministère de
l'Industrie a pu se dire qu'à 110 àheur
les automobilistes français seront
encore priv seraient encore privilégiés
même si en Allemagne fédérale à l'heure
de l'Europe la vitesse est seulement
recommandée à 130 àur sur autoroute mais
en réalité elle est libre et d'ailleurs
le ministre de l'Économie wouest
allemand vient de dire que si nous
adoptions
d'autres limitations de vitesse en
Allemagne nous construirions bientôt des
voitures techniquement aussi pitoyables
que les Américains vous voyez que ce
raisonnement va loin et dans ce
raisonnement on mélange facilement deux
problèmes la sécurité et les économies
d'énergie finalement donc l'hypothèse de
la limitation à 110 est écartée hier le
Premier ministre a fait ajourner le
Conseil interministériel qui devait
prendre un certain nombre de mesures
d'économie d'énergie ces mesures en tout
cas sont certaines il y en aura même
tout un éventail qui ne concernera pas
seul les automobilistes elles ne seront
annoncé ces mesures vraisemblablement
qu'après les élections européennes mais
avant les grands départs en vacances un
rappel des faits avec Catherine Mamet et
puis un commentaire d'Alain
vé pas question donc d'imposer de
nouvelles limitations de vitesse ce que
veulent les pouvoirs publics c'est faire
respecter les limitations en vigueur
cela permettrait d'économiser 600000
tonnes de pétrole par an c'est que si en
1975 un automobiliste sur 4 dépassait
les vitesses aorisé en 1977 ils étaient
un sur 3 et l'an dernier un sur de
police et gendarmerie viennent donc de
recevoir des consignes de sévérité quoi
qu'il en soit l'automobiliste risque de
faire d'une façon ou d'une autre les
frais de la chasse au gaspis le
ministère des Transports a calculé le
nombre de grammes de pétrole que vous
coûtez selon le mode de transport choisi
les résultats sont parfois surprenants
l'avion d'abord sur une ligne régionale
chaque passager coûte 160 g au kil m
c'est le record mais sur un Airbus
Paris-Marseille il ne coûte plus que 52
g et sur la ligne des Antilles en Boeing
747 29 g au km l'automobile peut coûter
beaucoup plus cher celui qui conduit
seul en ville à bord d'une grosse
cylindrée consomme 93 g trois fois plus
et 67 g s'il est à bord d'une petite
cylindrée sur autoroute avec deux
personnes à bord la grosse cylindrille
ne sera guerre plus économe que l'erbus
sur le trajet Paris-Marseille tandis que
la voiture moyenne de 7 chevaux
consommera 35 g on vous conseillera donc
le transport en commun classique 23 g
seulement pour le métro 21 pour
l'autocar et le train rapide te 18 pour
le train de banlieu et 15 pour L'Express
la première cible des chasseurs de gaspi
paraît évidente les grosses cylindret
qu'elles aient deux ou quatre roues y
aura-t-il des mesures contraignantes les
professionnels 5 nous comptons beaucoup
plus en ce qui nous concerne sur la
persuasion euh et une opération comme la
chasse au gaspi qui consiste à
responsabiliser les gens et à leur
apprendre à conduire mieux tout en en
conduisant parfois vite d'ailleurs mais
mieux est une opération bien plus
positive bien plus intéressante et nous
apportons notre soutien à ce type
d'opération au contraire des
réglementations contraignantes nous
paraissent déresponsabiliser totalement
les Français mais l'automobile ne
constituera pas la seule cible les
transports représentent moins de 20 % de
la consommation énergétique moins que le
chauffage or 1 degré de moins fait
économiser 7 % des dépenses de chauffage
en fait toutes les formes de
consommation seront passées en revue
avant les départs en
congé c'est l'emploi et surtout l'emploi
des jeunes qui sera demain le thème
central du Conseil des ministres on y
adoptera le 3è pacte national pour
l'emploi pour faciliter l'embauche de
400000 jeunes à la rentrée ce sera un
projet de loi qui sera soumis au
Parlement pour rentrer sans doute en
application le 1er juillet et pour au
moins 2 ans à ce propos je signale aux
jeunes un guide qui vient de sortir et
que j'ai là le guide antichômage 7980
intitulé l'aprèsbac un guide qui se
propose de déblayer les problèmes et de
donner des indications sur les filières
à suivre pour déboucher sur autre chose
que l'Agence nationale pour l'emploi
nous allons voir avec François Go quel
est ce qu'on a doit appeler hélas la
situation du marché de l'emploi pour les
jeunes sur 128 000 demandeurs d'emploi
498000 sont âgés de moins de 25 ans en
somme sur 100 demandeurs 39 sont des
jeunes voilà la réalité des chiffres fin
avril 1979 à présent examinons le détail
sur 100 jeunes demandeurs d'emploi 63
sont des femmes sur 100 et toujours fin
avril environ 10 sont à la recherche
d'un premier emploi enfin sur 100 et
cela aussi c'est important 60 trouent ou
retrouvent un emploi en moins de 3 mois
alors pourquoi existe-t-il un problème
particulier d'emploi pour les jeunes et
bien d'évidence parce que depuis 4 ans
l'activité économique s'est ralentie les
possibilités d'embauche se sont rarifié
premières victimes les jeunes et parce
que le chômage n'a épargné aucune
catégorie de salariés mais à cela
s'ajoutent trois réalités spécifiques
aux jeunes problème d'embouteillage
chaque année de juillet à novembre
650000 jeunes sont à la recherche d'un
premier emploi problème d'information
trop souvent elles font défaut entre le
système scolaire et l'entreprise
conséquence les jeunes attendent plus
longtemps leur premier emploi enfin
problème de formation par rapport aux
besoins des entreprises 40 % des jeunes
qui arrivent sur le marché du travail ne
possèdent aucun diplôme aucune
qualification professionnelle tous les
pays d'Europe connaissent aujourd'hui
une situation identique sur les 5900000
chômeurs que l'on compte dans la
Communauté européenne 40 % on retrouve
le même pourcentage
2400000 sont des jeunes
donc demain au Conseil des ministres les
mesures pour l'emploi des jeunes mais
aussi la mise en œuvre du nouveau régime
de l'indemnisation du chômage du chômage
économique comme on dit qui doit entrer
en vigueur lui aussi le 1er juillet avec
des régressions si vous vous vous en
souvenez sur les indemnisations c'est
demain également que reprennent les
négociations entre le CNPF et les
syndicats sur la réduction de la durée
du travail on a un peu tendance à mettre
de côté en ce moment les problèmes
sociaux autre que ceux de l'emploi sans
doute à cause du débat et des polémiques
autour de l'élection européenne je vous
rappelle tout de même que la CGT et la
CFDT se sont rencontrés hier pendant 3
He il n'en est rien sorti en tout cas
pour la presse je note aussi et surtout
ce que dit le syndicat chrétien CFTC
après la publication de l'indice des
prix hier 1 % de hausse en avril pour ce
syndicat l'aggravation de l'inflation
accentue l'urgence de véritabl
négociation salariales et puis à
l'Assemblée nationale aujourd'hui
c'était les travailleurs immigrés qui
était sur la Cellette il s'agissait de
modifier l'ordonnance de 1945 relative
aux conditions d'introduction et de
séjour des étranger en France ce débat
suscite une vive émotion chez les
4500000 immigrés vivants en France il y
a beaucoup d'inquiétude dans leur rang
mais aussi chez ceux qui partagent leurs
difficultés leurs soucis je citerai
simplement le début de l'éditorial de
Michel Noblecourt dans le journal La
Croix la France va-t-elle perdre sa
traditionnelle image de terre d'accueil
la question question mérite d'être posée
à propos de ce projet malvenu dans les
associations antiracistes et chez les
syndicats on se dit décid à agir contre
ce projet sur ce qui s'est passé en tout
cas aujourd'hui à l'Assemblée là-dessus
Alain Chaillou ce projet dit projet
barbonnais a en fait un triple objectif
contrôler plus strictement l'entrée des
étrangers sur le territoire national
poursuivre de manière plus efficace les
étrangers séjournant en situation
irrégulière enfin faciliter leur
expulsion en élargissant les cas où elle
peut être prononcé face à ce projet
l'opposition ind digné cri au scandal
elle parle je cite bien sûr de projet de
loi injuste arbitraire démagogique de
PES ouvertte à tous les abus de la
volonté du gouvernement d'expulser les
travailleurs du véritable appel au
racisme de faire des émigrés enfin les
bouqu émissaires de la crise alors qu'il
n'en sont que les premières victimes
pour la majorité au contraire c'est une
loi sévère certes c'est une loi
difficile sans doute mais c'est une loi
aussi indispensable le ministre de
l'Intérieur quant à lui face aux
attaques répond qu'il y a un malentendu
pour Monsieur bonnet ce projet n'a pas
d'autes autre but que de mieux contrôler
les flux migratoires et ne sont visés de
toute façon c'est ce qu'il dit que les
étrangers en situation irrégulière donc
une toute petite minorité à ses yeux les
autres au contraire ont droit c'est ce
qu'il affirme à la reconnaissance de
tous les Français pour le travail qu'ils
ont accompli le Parti socialiste avait
déposé une exception d'irrecevabilité le
Parti communiste une question au
préalable toutes deux ont été repoussé
la discussion a donc commencé une
discussion à la fois passionnée et
passionnelle le projet sera sans aucun
doute adopté assez tard dans la nuit à
après avoir été fortement
amendé vous avez pu le constater si vous
étiez à l'écoute à 19h40 la campagne
électorale officielle pour les élections
européennes a débuté à la télévision
nous avions ce soir les quatre
personnalités qui conduisent les grandes
listes celles que l'on appelle ainsi
parce qu'elles ont quelles sont les
émanations des principaux courants
politiques représentés à l'Assemblée
nationale et demain ce seront les
petites listes les têtes des petite
liste qui auront la parole mais à côté
de cette campagne officielle il y a
toujours les déclarations qui
fournissent des informations potiqu il y
a aussi des explications que vous
attendez certainement sur un certain
nombre de problèmes européens par
exemple ce soir qu'est-ce que le traité
de Rome tel sera le contenu du journal
des
européennes Michel Debray au monde il y
a dans la majorité des divergences sur
l'Europe tantôt elles sont
volontairement atténué et l'on parle de
convergence tantôt on accentue ces
divergences et l'on nous traite
d'anti-européens Michel Jobert quant à
lui préconise l'abstention le 10 juin
Olivier stirne vice-président du Parti
radical l'élection du 10 juin aurait pu
être pour François mitteran l'occasion
d'un nouveau départ curieusement elle
semble son champ du signe car le leader
socialiste apparaît étrangement
archaïque Michel cointa dans une lettre
à ses militants le RPR doit changer de
méthode sous peine de mort le député RPR
dit les vilaines qui ne soutient pas la
liste Chirac Debray car il la juge
anti-européenne estime que la liberté de
vote est possible et annonce qu'il ne
votera pour personne Jean-Jacques
servant schrebert propose à Jacques
Chirac un débat à la radio sur le thème
de l'Europe et de l'emploi d'accord dit
Jacques Chirac à Marseille mais à
condition d'avoir aussi un débat avec
Simone
veille le radical de gauche Roger Gérard
schwarenberg en confondant patriotisme
et chauvinisme Jacques Chirac et Michel
Debray semblent réchapper d'un musé
grvin de la politique Charles Tyon
ancien membre de la direction du PC
figure parmi les signataires d'une
motion de soutien à la liste socialiste
Jean-Marie Le Pen qui s'est prononcé lui
aussi pour l'abstention vient d'adresser
une lettre au président de la République
il demande au chef de l'État s'il couvre
de sa haute autorité les pratiques de la
campagne électorale que le Front
national juge antidémocratique et puis
le traité de Rome qui prévoit depuis
1957 l'élection de l'assemblée
européenne au suffrage universel direct
comment a-t-il été préparé quelles sont
ces clauses principales Florence
chal en 1950 l'objectif de Robert
Schuman un des fondateurs de l'Europe
était l'union politique union politique
préparée par la création de solidarité
économique telle que la Communauté
européenne du charbon et de l'acier le
25 mars 57 en signant le traité de Rome
six États la République fédérale
d'Allemagne la Belgique la France
l'Italie le Luxembourg et les Pays-Bas
ont créé la Communauté économique
européenne trois nouveaux membres le
Danemark l'Irlande et le Royaume-Uni y
ont adhéré en janvier 72 mais les
signataires du traité de Rome n'ont pas
réalisé les vœux de Schuman cette
communauté se fixait sur tout pour
objectif l'unification des politiques
économiques ainsi que la suppression des
droits de douane et la libre circulation
des hommes et des capitaux la politique
restait du domaine des relations
interétatiques
formons une commission
politique une commission de défense et
une commission culturelle tout de même
que nous avons déjà une commission
économique à Bruxelles qui étudie les
questions
le traité de Rome ne dit pas exactement
quelles sont les compétences de la
Communauté et celles des étatsmembres et
de plus le mécanisme d'élaboration des
actes communautaires est très complexe
deux organ de décision et d'action la
Commission et le Conseil de ministres
deux organ de consultation et deôle
l'Assemblée parlementaire et la Cour de
justice le Conseil formé par tous les
ministres desaires étrangères arrête les
règlements communautaires mais ne peut
se prononcer que sur proposition de la
Commission
formé de 13 membres indépendants des
gouvernements la Commission est le chien
degarde du marché commun elle veille à
ce que les États respectent les
décisions communautaires parallèlement
l'Assemblée parlementaire composée des
représentants des peuples des
États-membres n'exerce en fait qu'un
pouvoir de consultation tandis que la
Cour de justice composée de magistrats
indépendants veille à ce que le droit
communautaire prime dans chaque État sur
les droits nationaux dès 1974 le
développement politique de la
construction EUR eurne a rendu
nécessaire l'élection au suffrage
universel de l'Assemblée le 10 juin les
peuples européens éliront 410
parlementair dont 81 français l'élection
du 10 juin donnera-t-elle plus de
pouvoir à cette assemblée là est toute
la question du débat
actuel jean-l burger les autres
nouvelles importantes de ce journal la
spéculation sur l'or se poursuit surt
les marchés internationaux 205 francs de
plus qu'ier sur le lingo ce matin à
Paris la hausse s'est déplacée aussi sur
le Napoléon et sur la rente 4 et demi%73
qui pour la première fois a franchi la
barre des 1000 francs la normalisation
des relations entre l'Égypte et Israël
se fera que sous condition de
réciprocité absolue a déclaré ce matin
monsieur Moché Dayan au Conseil des
ministres israélien jusqu'à présent
apparemment tout se passe bien puisqu'on
a assisté hier à l'arrivée des premiers
navires de guerre israéliens dans le
canal de Sue
parallèlement dans la même journée
Israël a libéré un nouveau contingent de
prisonniers arabes conformément à la
promesse faite dimanche par Monsieur
Bégin au président Sadat il s'agit
d'homme capturés en 6 Jordanie Jérusalem
a annoncé d'autres mesures de clémence
en faveur de deux nouveaux groupes de
détenus manifestation des grévistes de
la solem sur la voie ferrée
Paris-Marseille à la gare de Miramas la
ligne a été coupé et plusieurs trains
immobilisés dont le mistral de part et
d'autre du barrage la munition mpalité
de labaule a fait appel au militaires
cet après-midi pour nettoyer les 20 km
de plage de la Côte d'Amour la marée
avait apporté ses jours dernier et
encore ce matin de larges plaques de
mazout provenant semble-t-il de
pétroliers qui avaient dégazé en mer
quelques rochers de la côte sauvag ont
été aussi souillés par le pétrole mais
ce dernier paraissait lui venir beaucoup
plus loin venir du Golfe de
gascon aucun danger pour la population
pour l'instant à Saint-Denis de la
Réunion cependant la faille qui s'est
ouverte dans les flancs du volcan la
fournaise mesure 150 m de large et une
énorme coulée de lave s'en échappe en
descendant heureusement en direction de
la mer décès du docteur Jean solomidè ce
médecin s'était rendu récemment célèbre
en vendant un médicament miracle contre
le cancer en fait ce médicament avait
été sévèrement mis en cause par
plusieurs professeurs français dont le
professeur Jean-Bernard en décembre
dernier le docteur solomides malgré le
soutien de nombreuses personnalités
avaient été condamné à fermer son
laboratoire et à la saisie du matériel
cependant son médicament n'a jamais été
testé par les services officiels ni par
les cancérologues son comité de soutien
précise d'ailleurs ce soir que la
campagne pour l'expérimentation de ce
médicament continuera le docteur
solomides est mort d'une congestion
pulmonaire inauguré par Jean-Louis
guilla président de TF1 ouverture
aujourd'hui Porte de Versailles à Paris
du 3e Salon International de la
communication publicitaire 17 pays sont
représentés ce salon a pour but de
permettre les contacts direct entre les
professionnels de la publicité le public
et les responsables de l'État et de la
presse en France les annonceurs
publicitaires ont dépensé cette année
plus de 9000 millions de francs qui se
décomposent ainsi plus de 5000 millions
dans la presse et 1500 millions à la
télévision TF1 la régie française de
publicité ont un stand dans ce salon qui
fermera ses portes le premier jour décès
à grâce de Madame de saint-exupéri
l'épouse du célèbre écrivain et pionnier
de l'aviation originaire du sint
Salvador con madame conuello
saintexupéri était aux États-Unis
lorsqu'elle avait appris la disparition
de
saintex l'opéré du cœur de créteille est
dans un état satisfaisant son identité
n'a toujours pas été divulguée on sait
seulement que c'est un homme de 34 ans
c'est la 423e greffe cardiaque dans le
monde depuis décembre
67 enfin premièrees pêch dans le
Rousillon elles sont un peu en retard
cette année les pêches par rapport à
l'année dernière une quinzaine de jours
mais elles seront paraît-il bien
meilleures et la récolte devrait être
supérieure de 20 %. et cela nous amène
tout naturellement au temp qu'il fait et
qu'il fera alors pour aujourd'hui hausse
générale ou à peu près des températures
en tout cas dans le nord-est baisse dans
le Sud-Ouest et souvent en tout cas sur
le pays aux tendances orageuses parfois
très prononcé comme sur Paris demain
matin le temps restera très nuageux très
orageux sur une bonne moitié de la
France de la frontière belge au au
Pyréné sur l'ouest un temps plus frais
et variable est annoncé
enfin vous voyez que les nuages blancs
là sont sont pleins de nuages gris ce
qui signifie bien tendance à l'orage à
Roland Garros cet après-midi c'était
même pour les grands champions de tennis
le passage difficile des qualifications
or le super champion a connu lui aussi
des difficultés c'est Borg mais le
public qui a assisté dans l'indifférence
à l'élimination de Geoffrey a fait de
Noah son enfant chéri un match contre
l'Américain Martin qui fut loin d'être
techniquement parfait mais qui qui fut
gagné à l'arraché en 57 et qui fut
surtout véritablement passionnant et
même halant comme on
dit les 10000 spectateurs de Roland
Garros attendaient l'entrée des deux
grandes vedettes aujourd'hui dans le
tournoi des Internationaux de France
Jimmy conors qui jouait un peu
l'arlaisienne depuis 5 ans a éliminé au
premier tour son compatriote
terryour John Borg qui rencontrait ce
matin le tchoslovaque Thomas n'a pas
convaincu ses supporters ce n'était pas
du grand Borg tel qu'on l'avait vu l'an
dernier celui qui n'avait concédé aucun
set à ses adversaire aujourd'hui en
effet il a quelqu peu peiné pour
éliminer SMI en 47 61 57 64 64 mais
n'oublions pas qu'il était encore
handicapé il y a à peine 8 jours par une
élongation musculaire à la
cuisse le jeune français Yannick Noa
n'est pas encore une grande vedette mais
il a enthousiasmé le public en se
battant avec une fougue étonnante contre
l'Américain Bill Martin qui n'est classé
que 100e au classement mondial peu Avard
de ses efforts Noah se jetait
littéralement sur les balles et
parvenait ainsi à éliminer son
adversaire en 47 75 67 62 67
73 ah oui se jetait sur les Valles les
rues des grandes villes réservées aux
enfants le mercredi après-midi voilà ce
qu' avait recommandé le ministère de
l'environnement dans le cadre de l'année
de l'enfant et bien 10 grandes villes en
France ont répondu à cette initiative
manos angangoulet anger Charleville
méière aras Brest charte Narbonne Lille
et Lyon dans ces villes et dans certains
quartiers en tout cas de ces villes les
ruses seront piétonnières comme on dit
le mercredi après-midi et comme il n'y
aura pas de voiture on pourra s'amuser
en toute liberté pour cela des
volontaires s'ingéiront j'en suis sûr et
ça continuera à animer ces quartiers
c'est déjà le cas dans les rues d'Angers
un reportage de Christian de la
croix à anger tout comme à angoulem ou à
La Rochelle quelle est donc la place de
l'enfant dans la ville face aux
obstacles aux interdictions et au
dangers redonner un espace urbain à ces
jeunes pour leur permettre de mieux
vivre dans leur environnement immédiat
c'est l'objectif de l'opération
expérimentale les rues du mercredi elle
consiste à fermer une fois par semaine à
la circulation automobile et à ouvrir
aux enfants certaines rues dans les
villes en créant une animation libre
priorité est donné au quartiers qui
manque d'espace vert ou d'animation
culturelle et les enfants viennent un
peu surpris d'avoir cet espace de jeu
bien à eux et d'exercer en toute liberté
des activités diverses pour réaliser ce
type d'action la délégation à la qualité
de la vie s'adresse au mairie qui après
accord contacte les collectivités
locales et les associations de quartiers
le coût de l'opération subventionné à 50
% et d'environ pour les municipalités de
de 10 à 20000 francs par
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
an mais fermer des places et des rues de
9h du matin à 18h est-ce que cela ne
crait pas trop de perturbation de gênees
et d'embouteillage dans les villes non
d'abord les automobilistes adapte à
trouver des parkings nouveaux dans le
centre les habitants du quartier
trouvent un peu une animation nouvelle
et en fonction de ça et bien quelque
chose de sympathique se déroule et
aujourd'hui ici dans le centre hier dans
les quartiers périphériques de la ville
et apparemment les choses se passent
dans la bonne humeur qu'est-ce que tu as
fait aujourd'hui j'ai fait un gâteau en
sucre un gâteau est-ce qu'il éit réussi
oui j'ai fait des
[Musique]
ballons me
maquiller comment est-ce que tu passes
tes mercredis d' habitude je regarde la
télévision dites-nous un peu ce que vous
a apporté ce mercredi à toutes les deux
c'est mieux on peut être on peut sortir
on peut c'est mieux on
ensemble à anger les mercredis sont
devenus jour de fête grâce à une
animation réussie reste à souhaiter que
l'expérience s'étend à beaucoup d'autres
villes et qu'elle se poursuive même
au-delà de l'année de
l'enfance c'est vrai que les rues
s'ennuient sans les enfants alors si ça
peut changer quelque part en France le
mercredi c'est très bien bonne soirée à
tous et à toutes au nom de toute
l'équipe de TF1 actualité dernier
journal Jean-Louis Burga à 23h30 vers
23h30
[Musique]
merci